hi I'm Rachel and I'm a tasty producer
and today I'm going to try to create a
homemade tofu Turkey so I don't think
this should be too hard this is like
something I found on the side of the
road created a monster
so what I'm basing this off of is the
iconic tofurkey I'm just gonna slice
this open and do some research
wow that is dense wow it's so cute it's
got a little stuffing in the middle so
I'm just gonna try some of this with my
giant fork okay
so it's like pretty rubbery not the best
flavor it kind of tastes like baloney
but worse I feel like a turkey should
have little drumsticks you know and I
feel like that'd be really cool to try
to recreate and for those of you at home
who are wondering why I want to eat
something that resembles a turkey when
I'm vegan because I didn't give up meat
because I don't like the taste of meat I
used to absolutely love Turkey and I
want to see if I can recreate that taste
I think I'm gonna ask someone else to
try this I want your honest opinion on
this tofurkey
it's very rubbery it's very dense if it
looks more like a turkey I feel like
that would be better for me because I'm
not a vegetarian are you gonna try to
fix this I mean I try to make my own and
see what I can come up with well that
I'm excited for so yeah I wait to try
that I mean I hope I can do better than
that
that's gonna be like a huge lunch this
might be what we're having for dinner
Boop so the first thing I'm gonna do is
use all of the water out of this tofu
has a pretty high water retention and
getting all the moisture out is just
gonna let it absorb whatever flavor you
want it to take on I wonder if people
ever thought about making like tofu milk
source casting I don't know why even
saying that oh right so we're gonna add
the tofu to a food processor because you
can't have a Tofurky without tofu I'm
going to add nutritional yeast a lot of
people use nutritional yeast as like a
cheesy flavor I think it actually gives
it more of like a savory kind of like
Mommie flavor
umami now I'm gonna do garlic 2
teaspoons of poultry seasoning which
does not have any chicken products in it
actually onion powder pepper soy sauce
is super important so we're going to
blend this puppy up
so now I'm gonna transfer my tofu
concoction into this big bowl nothing
like some tofu paste to get the party
started
this is gonna be a turkey I swear now
I'm going to add a very essential
ingredient so this is called vital wheat
gluten gluten is the main protein of
wheat and it's a great meat substitute
because it has a really chewy meaty
texture they're gonna kind of form like
a giant gluten dough ball I'm going to
attempt to mold it into this like little
Bowl I have this is my mom stuffing
recipe shout out to you Carla so let's
try this just going to try to make like
a little dome it's gonna punch hole in
the middle it feels so weird I feel like
I'm in pottery class I'm just gonna
stuff it I think I might be too much
okay I'm just gonna see laughs little
butt up let's see if this thing comes
out oh look it's a little turkey dome
wow I really lubed his fellow up he is
slick so I'm just gonna wrap him and
parsh my paper first and then in foil
now I'm just gonna take this to the oven
and hope he transforms into a little
perfect tofu Turkey I just pulled this
out of the oven and I'm nervous to see
what he looks like
whoa it's a little turkey he's so cute I
like how it's really golden and then it
has this weird like soft spot on the top
like a little soft spot on a baby's head
and I don't know why that is a thing Wow
okay tofu Turkey I'm gonna try it and
see where we're at
this is not good this is perfect back it
looked pretty decent and this tastes
like the bottom of a sneaker that is
what it tastes like
just lay it on me and it's gonna be a no
for me though is it really that bad
Rachel I'm so sorry
what is in there oh I stopped him him I
feel like you're Topher cues
gender-neutral pronoun they they them it
jiggles I ate literally jiggles hold on
can I be asleep don't what I'm going to
do is Collin well who is my fellow vegan
comrade slash boss slash spirit animal
who will hopefully know how to fix this
I was like wet bread that's been sitting
in a closet for like a week the vegans
and the vegetarians and even the meteors
deserve better than this you can get on
this so this is interesting because even
though this is a Tofurky you would think
the first ingredient would be tofu but
it's actually wheat gluten which makes
me think maybe I should cut down on the
tofu and actually up the wheat gluten
especially since the wheat gluten is
like the really chewy part and since
this is like so soft I'm wondering if
that could help maybe add a little bit
more of the poultry seasoning crank that
salt up jazz it up a little bit yeah
let's do this I'm going to decrease the
tofu from three blocks to one block I
mean it's good that it's so dense
because I think that's gonna help with
the texture trying to like seal up this
giant that I've made Jesus I'm also
going to make my little drumsticks this
time so I'm gonna cut off nope
damn it this is big I mean honestly this
isn't bad from a distance you could like
pull this right out of the KFC bucket
and now you're gonna want to slide that
stick right into its DMS this is
probably the weirdest thing I've ever
done for my job I'm just gonna bake them
along with my little tofu turkey okay
this is attempt number two he's a little
lumpy but that's because it was like a
lot of thicker and harder to work wind
Cheers
oh wow that is chewier oh okay freaked
me out as much texture is definitely
better when you lose definitely more
meat like yeah and less spongy let's
crack these puppies open
[Music]
it's so cute wait that looks like will
drumstick if you bready that I didn't
put stuff on it
drum roll please oh wow you have to take
the the legs out fun fact the wing
should come out of the oven before the
tofurkey cuz they're smaller its feel
like magnets
this time I cited to try adding some
pinto beans because the tofu gives off a
little bit of a spongy texture
the wheat gluten could be a little bit
doughy and so we think the beans might
kind of give it more of that like
in-between meatiness I also dialed the
wheat gluten back a tiny bit by a half a
cup think that might do the trick
this is attempt number three just took
it out of the oven it looks good I am
very optimistic right now let's pray
that this is good because I am NOT
making this thing again I will if I have
to but I'd rather not moment of truth
guys hey she's back we're doing this
thing it looks really good this is
promising your's okay Cheers
that is way better man that is so so
much yeah not only is it better than the
other two attempts it's way better than
actual tober wait we frickin did it no
you did a tofu turkey okay oh yeah I
need to get an actual meat-eater in here
to see if this is the real deal so you
don't just hear it from a bunch of
vegans wow it's like Blue Ribbon this
year oh my gosh I never thought this day
would come even if you eat meat and you
just wanted to see what the process of
making something vegan is like that's
totally awesome fine and I hope you
learn something and maybe try something
like this sometime and I hope that if
you're vegan and you are in an area
where you don't have a lot of options or
access to different kinds of like meat
alternatives that now you have a recipe
in your arsenal that you can whip up
anytime you want cool
audio haka way and the same
save a turkey ride a tofu turkey are
read a gluten beans soy bomb
[Music]
you
[Music]